[Music]
welcome to the science podcast for
February 22nd 2019 i'm sara press b in
this week's show we'd go to the triple-s
annual meeting in washington DC and I
talked with Cathy Binger about using
technology to help kids with
communication disorders and despite what
you may have heard at this point iPads
in the internet have not solved all the
problems I also talked with freelancer
Sarah Scholz about using satellites and
artificial intelligence to spot
modern-day slavery from space and
Valerie Thompson is back for this
month's book segment she talks with
author Judy grizzle about her book never
enough the neuroscience and experience
of addiction I'm at the triple a s
meeting in Washington DC today we're
talking with Cathy Binger about using
technology to help people with impaired
communication hi Cathy hi how are you
Sarah I'm really good and this is such
an interesting topic because I think
when you say using technology to help
with communication people are going to
think the internet or mobile phones
those are things that help you with
communication and it's true that these
kinds of technologies have helped people
but they're not the magic bullet and in
your session you know you talked a lot
about the complexities of helping people
with communication disorders so what
kind of communication problems do you
work with I personally work with young
children who have communication problems
so they can have any of a range a very
wide range of communication issues it
can be children with cerebral palsy who
also have motor impairments it can be
children with Down syndrome or any of a
number of other syndromes that cause
speech impairment or have speech
impairments associated with them or it
can be with very young children often we
don't know what's really going on the
story that you'll often see in a
newspaper for example would be they show
a picture of a kid with an iPad and this
kid wasn't talking and then the iPad
came home with the parents some app they
bought and now the kid is talking
unfortunately that's not how it works
can you talk a little bit about some of
the complexities that come into things
we can boil some of the complexities
down into three tips for communication
so we have the tea
the t is for technology and that is and
can be a very important piece but we
also have an eye in tips which stands
for instruction so we need instruction
both for the child and also for the
people who communicate with the child so
educators and families etc and then we
have the P which is for personalization
and all throughout the process including
the technology including the instruction
needs to be personalized to meet the
very individualized needs of each child
I think a really good example that came
up amongst the different speakers was
you work with kids a lot of these apps
or these screens have icons or symbols
on them because the kids aren't reading
but someone who is an adult that already
has an experience with reading they
might rely on letters and spelling and
so this personalization it absolutely
has to happen depending on who the
patient is right it would be fantastic
if we could teach two and
three-year-olds how to read and then
that would really solve the problem
because all they would need in English
at least would be 26 letters and off
they go
but that's not how it works lots of our
kids are very young and they certainly
need to communicate when they're very
very young we also have children who
have cognitive impairments intellectual
impairments who are going to be delayed
with their reading and so we can't wait
until kids can type letters in order to
help them communicate so we need to look
at other ways to help them while we're
really pushing for and supporting early
literacy skills so we do want to push
early literacy but of course that's not
going to happen for every child at a
young age this came up I think with you
in another speaker you're not just
getting these kids or these adults to
communicate their most basic needs you
also want them to develop language
skills and you also want them to
communicate with people like commune
that part of it like actually be in a
relationship with a person using
language there's some data that's been
out for a really long time now multiple
decades it shows that young children up
to age five you might think that what
they're mostly doing is requesting
things and that tends to be the kind of
stuff that we give kids access to right
like I want you so I want crackers but
in fact this old research shows that
less than 20% of children's early
communications are really focused on
requesting they're commenting they're
showing you things they
to say you know social words and
greetings and communication is so rich
even for very very young children even
before children who are typically
developing learn to talk their pointing
things out and commenting and all of
that so we need to make sure we're
giving children access to a full range
of communication opportunities you know
when my daughter was born we got on the
train and try to do a little sign
language with her and that is something
that would be frowned upon maybe a
decade ago people thought if you keep
your kid sign language they're not going
to learn speech of course that's not
true and I feel like this is also
something that came up in your talk
today with you know using technology
absolutely and of course sign language
is part of augmentative communication
it's taken a while but we now have a
good body of research that's growing
that shows not only that using
technology won't prevent speech from
developing but we have some new findings
coming out including randomized
controlled trials showing that can
actually help children and speed up
their communication and that's something
those of us who work clinically we've
known that you know seeing that for many
years but the research is starting to
catch up to that and we're starting to
have some good data to back that up
so it's an understandable fear that
parents have that children are not going
to communicate or they're not going to
want to talk if they're using this
technology that just doesn't happen one
of the beautiful things about using
technology to communicate is when they
get that speech signal every time they
hear a word every time they hear the
word I or am or house or whatever they
hear it exactly the same way and if
their child who has problems processing
language getting that speech signal in
in the same way every time may be
helping them now when we talk about a
child looking at a grid of symbols or
pointing to something or using the
speech coming out of a technological
device we're not talking about a
specific app there is no miracle app to
get your kid to talk instead it's got to
be a suite of tools I think it's really
important to get the message across that
it's not a matter of us waiting for a
magic app to be developed people have
been waiting for that and working on
that for a long time and I think it's
the wrong question the question is what
does this
child Neen given this child's whole
array of factors including their
personal factors right what their
cognitive level is what their speech
level is what their motor abilities are
etc and then what their broader
environmental picture is like there are
things that work but you're gonna have
to kind of pull from all these different
areas to serve one kids needs right we
do something that we've been doing for
the past several decades now called
feature matching we look at the child
and look at the child's characteristics
and look at the family and all of the
complexities that come along with that
child and what we want to do is we want
to look at what not only apps but also
other types of AAC devices that are out
there it might not be an iPad that works
and figure out what kinds of things do
we need to do to fill in their
communication needs based on this
particular child so it could be doing
some sign language along with an
high-tech communication app along with
something that's low-tech for when that
communication app breaks down because it
is going to break down at some point and
we need to make sure that child has
access to communication you know a lot
of these things are iPads there there's
something that anybody would recognize
and has that helped get this into the
hands of kids that maybe their parents
wouldn't want them to use technology
instead of just focusing on speech
absolutely that's been a huge
game-changer we've been doing this kind
of thing for a long time they were just
very small companies by and large with
highly highly specialized devices once
the iPad came out I actually looked it
up yesterday the first full-blown iPad
app for communication came out 10 years
ago we've all been going through this
sea change in my world in my discipline
about how to handle all that there are
both things that have been huge
blessings and things that have been
drawbacks the huge blessings have been
the normalizing piece where you know my
kids now look like every other kid and
they get to be the cool kids sometimes
because they get to have their iPad when
other kids are not allowed to have their
iPad so that's fun like they get to be
the kid that other kids want to be with
which is not something that often
happens for the children I work with and
then there are some challenges too where
again you know lots of families they see
something on TV or YouTube or wherever
Twitter feed and they go out and buy
some
without getting an assessment and that's
where the trouble really comes in
because that may not be the best tool
for them it might not be the best
hardware it might not be the best
software and they maybe they just blew
$700 for nothing that they could have
put towards something else it's going to
be more appropriate for the child so
it's that undoing of that process is the
challenging piece right now but there
have been many blessings with the
changing technology as well ok Kathy
thank you so much you're very welcome
Sarah thank you Kathy Binger is an
associate professor at the University of
New Mexico you could find a link to her
session and her laboratory website at
science mag - stay tuned for an
interview with freelance science
journalist Sarah schools about using
satellites to spot modern-day slavery
[Music]
we can see a lot from space these days
the resolution of satellite imagery lets
us see things like roads buildings even
people though those tend to be pretty
low definition you know about three
pixels per person freely in science
journalist sarah schools is here to talk
about spotting something a little
different
seeing slavery with satellites hi Sarah
hi thank you for having me
oh sure so the first question I have and
I'm sure a lot of people have is what
does slavery look like from space the
biggest example that researchers have so
far involves looking for brick kilns
which are these very large structures
that are kind of oval shaped where
people make bricks and researchers know
from intelligence on the ground that
these use a high proportion of forced
labour and slave labor and they're easy
to spot from space because they're big
and Avila where are those located on the
face of the earth they're located in a
region conveniently called the brick
belt which is in South Asia it spins a
number of countries researchers involved
in this work are also using satellites
from the European Space Agency and
they're actually looking in other
wavelengths not you know things that are
visible to the eye but for other kinds
of frequencies what can they find using
that system yeah using a satellite
called Sentinel 2 which sees frequencies
that your eyes can't detect
researchers can actually tell what kinds
of minerals are on the surface of the
earth and so they can differentiate
different kinds of mining and they know
that certain types of mining are using
lots of slave labour then there's
another kind of satellite that uses
radar so kind of sends microwaves at the
ground bounces them back and detects how
they've changed and that kind of
intelligence can actually show mining
tunnels where people are working because
the ground subsides a little bit beneath
them Wow one last thing that you
mentioned briefly in the story you
didn't really elaborate on but I did
remember hearing a podcast on this and
that's using ship tracking to own it on
slavery how does that work so
researchers know where ships should be
going and where they shouldn't be going
and when they detect from looking at
these ships from space that they are
turning off their trackers and going
places they shouldn't go that's
suspicious illegal activity that might
be connected to slavery and they can
also see ships kind of lining up with
other ships docking with them
essentially in transferring you know
illegal cargo or people who they're
treating illegally right well one thing
I noticed about these different methods
is they all rely on a lot of information
about how these things work it's not
just taking pictures it's figuring out
what these pictures mean so how are they
working together with the people who
know that slavery looks like a brick
kiln right you can't do any of this
investigation from space without
actually knowing what's going on on the
ground so they start with people who
work at nongovernmental organizations on
the ground or organizations like the UN
who have been in these regions and
actually you know found these instances
of forced labour in person and then they
use those examples to generalize into
space and look for those signs but then
once they have those they also have to
go back to the ground and say you know
was that ship just having a bad day or
were they doing something bad so it's
really all about the ground even though
we're doing it from space and then it's
also to some extent about machine
learning and AI because there's a lot of
growl
to cover how how is machine learning
involved in finding these different
sites the biggest example we have right
now goes back to those brick kilns
because they are so easily identifiable
researchers at the University of
Nottingham which runs an organization
called the Wrights lab have taught a
machine learning algorithm to recognize
these brick kilns and then had it
searched through an example area to see
if it can pick out brick kilns on its
own without input from people and it's
doing that to a fairly high degree of
accuracy but it's still kind of in its
its nascent stages and so anything that
is recognizable into stings like a kiln
or you know unusual shipping activity
researchers can train an artificial
intelligence algorithm to recognize that
kind of strange activity what happens
next
say they see it from space they check
and say yeah that did happen or that
kiln is there how is this information
being used to prevent these things from
happening or stop them right that's a
good question because you could do all
of this analysis and then just kind of
let it sit in a white paper if you
wanted but what the researchers
especially at the Wrights lab are trying
to do is pass that information to the
NGOs on the ground and then also to a
policy organization the United Nations
has called Delta 8.7 which brings
together these artificial intelligence
experts and satellite experts and policy
makers to try to actually do something
about it so the information doesn't just
sit on someone's computer very
interesting that actually brings up
something that's happening relatively
soon and the UN is holding a meeting to
try to bring all these different groups
together to kind of improve on this the
UN's think tank is holding a conference
called code seven on February 19th and
20th that is bringing together all these
people who know a lot about the things
they know about like slavery or like
artificial intelligence but who maybe
don't know about each other's realms of
expertise to try to get the people who
own the satellites to understand what
slavery looks like and to get the people
who under
Stanwell Avery looks like to understand
how it looks from a satellite and you
try to just fuse these technologies into
something that is useful on the ground
okay thank you so much Sarah thank you
for having me Sarah's goals is a
freelance science journalist based in
Denver you can find a link to her
article at science mag podcasts next up
we have books editor Valerie Thompson
speaking with author Judy grisel about
her work never enough the neuroscience
and experience of addiction
you
welcome back to the book segment of the
science podcast I'm Valerie Thompson the
book review editor here at science today
our guest is neuroscientist Judy grisel
who's here to discuss her new book never
enough the neuroscience and experience
of addiction Judy thanks so much for
being here thanks Valerie so let's get
started the book project was more than a
professional never for you it was also
pretty personal so before we dive into
the book itself can you talk a little
bit about your relationship with
addiction sure my first experience with
intoxication completely altered my
life's trajectory I was 13 and felt like
the large amount of alcohol I consumed
somehow fill the void some people I
think say it's like a hole in the soul
but it made me feel comfortable with
myself and capable of handling the pain
of living or of growing up or being an
adolescent and so for about the next 10
years or so I never said no to a single
opportunity to change the way I felt of
course eventually from that I was pretty
hopeless and also homeless and had lost
quite a lot but I ended up in treatment
at 23 and when I learned about the
disease model and that it was best
treated with abstinence which didn't
sound great to me I figured that
diseases could be cured so I got right
on it
it's funny most addicts and I was like
most I guess really are so determined
that there must be a way to keep using
and that's I think while we drive
ourselves into the ground well obviously
there's no single lever but you do study
beta-endorphin
and that has been linked with alcohol
addiction so how does that work I should
go back to my original plan though and
how naive I was because I thought well
it's a disease I'll just find the the
single lever or so that caused the
disease and then I'll fix that
and what I learned in graduate school in
a postdoc in years of researching in the
field is that there are many many such
levers one that I have knowledge about
and it's a focus of my particular
research is beta-endorphin but again
it's just one of many factors
and beta endorphin levels are normally
distributed in the population so there's
people who have naturally high and
naturally low levels and that happens to
be correlated with your inherited risk
so if you have a lot of alcoholics in
your family you're more likely to have
low levels and if you have none in your
family or more likely to have high
levels what's really interesting to me
about that is that alcohol stimulates
the synthesis and the release of beta
endorphin and it especially does this in
people who have the high risk so they
start out lower but they can really
effectively self-medicate that
deficiency by drinking and so I assume
that one of these people who drinks or
gets their first or you know early
experience with alcohol would think it's
fantastic because suddenly they feel you
know full of endorphin not that they'd
recognize that's the cause
whereas for somebody with low risk it
probably doesn't have a big influence on
that pathway so we're kind of at a more
granular level here but there's also
these kind of higher level societal
trends so for example you described this
relationship between the 60s and
anti-anxiety drugs and so now we're in
the midst of the opioid epidemic how
does this fit with this view of society
and drug use kind of reflecting each
other I think the the main point is that
manipulating or neuro chemistry to
change the way we think and feel and
behave is ancient and universal so
there's always going to be something but
it is interesting that the fads kind of
come and go and opiate use has been
rising steadily over the past several
years especially among young people it's
worth noting though since we just left
alcohol that there's much more alcohol
abuse and addiction than opiate abuse
and addiction but anyway it is it's
rising and there are many factors I'm
sure involved inada but I do think
possibly we're attempting to medicate
suffering because opiates are really an
antidote to suffering they're not an
antidote to pain as much as they are
caring about the pain and I think
that we're both suffering individually
but also certainly may be more aware of
the suffering of others and that is
painful to look at so I wonder whether
or not we're in a time and place where
this is going up so high that we don't
the amount of suffering we experience or
we perceive is just driving a need to
escape you talk about something I've
never heard of before in your book anti
opiates can you talk about what those
are and how more generally the brain and
the body compensate for the effects of
drugs sure the kind of core of my
argument is that the brain adapts to any
drug that changes its feeling state or
the way we feel by producing the
opposite effect
so stimulants regularly used make us
lethargic and sedatives regularly used
make us tense and anxious and opiates
regularly used make us suffer pain is
really critical to our survival and
therefore it's mediated by a rich
neurobiology there are many circuits and
neuro chemicals involved in modulating
pain some of these blocked pain like
endorphins as we just talked about but
others may be less well known enhance
pain that's because it's important to
our survival both to be able to ignore
pain and to experience it when it's time
to attend to the pain so early studies
even in 1980 for instance Hanh showed
that if you took a brain extract from
morphine tolerant animals it caused an
immediate tolerance in other animals
that were otherwise naive and taking
cerebral spinal fluid from morphine
dependent rats caused abstinence in
other rats
so these scientists were arguing that
something was produced by the brain to
produce the opposite effect there's
whole dozens really of anti opiates that
are proposed to be upregulated or
increased in
response to chronic opiate exposure and
the consequences of those chemicals
would be to produce the opposite effect
so instead of constipation they might
mediate diarrhea or instead of locking
pain they might enhance it how does the
person who's withdrawing from the drug
like what is their experience then when
they when these chemicals are being
released the experience of withdrawing
from any drug is always the exact
opposite of the acute effects of the
drug understanding what causes that
experience depends on the particular
drug were discussing but in the case of
opiates some of that experience of
suffering of not being able to sleep of
being restless of feeling so sick is
likely caused by the release of anti
opiate compounds Erik word alack did the
study in the 1990s and he had rats who
were releasing opiates to deal with what
they expected to be a stressful
situation and then there was a signal
that indicated that the stressful
situation went away and as soon as that
happened they released something that
completely blocked
morphine's effects so we can see that
the body is capable of enhancing and
attenuating our pain states kind of on a
dime and so that requires neuro
chemicals how does that jive with like
how we treat addictions now is that
knowing that the brain has all these
compensatory mechanisms how should we be
treating addictive States so in general
those compensatory mechanisms have to
take some time to go away because
they're in place in order to help us
maintain homeostasis so if we like I'm
completely addicted to caffeine if I
wake up in the morning and try to have a
conversation before I have coffee I
can't really put a sentence together so
if I wanted to withdraw from that
dependence I would probably take days
and maybe weeks to get back to a normal
state where I could wake up without
so I think part of it is giving a person
time and space away from their drugs so
that they could be detoxified in a way
that the acute phase of withdrawal and
craving was you know not so intense but
also it might be worth figuring out ways
to facilitate that adaptation back to a
naive state there is with opiates a way
to do that and everybody's probably
heard of narcan which is a drug that's
used to treat overdoses
but it would be possible to speed up the
return to a naive brain state by giving
huge doses of narcan of course nobody
who's an addict wants to experience that
effect because it will make them they
don't want to experience narcan because
it will make them go into withdrawal but
you could and people do occasionally get
anesthetized during that acute
withdrawal phase so they spend two or
three days kind of knocked out with
narcan on board which helps bring the
brain state back to a baseline a naive
baseline and then they're not
experiencing withdrawal when they wake
up of course they recognize that state
and they realize they could also go get
high so often it results in a quick
relapse so you mentioned kind of the
difficulties of getting adolescents in
particular to avoid experimenting with
drugs how does your research in your own
experience as an addict kind of inform
your how you talk to the young people in
your life about drugs well you know
people say they'll do what you do not
what you say so I feel a little
tentative to be saying too much because
of course I'm not a great example of
this but I have tried to talk to my
students and my own children about this
particularly sensitive period of brain
development adolescent brain development
when the behaviors that they engage in
can produce these lasting much more
lasting changes in the brain so for
instance I tried to say to my own kids
if you could avoid using any addictive
substance until you were 23 which I
thought was a good time then I will buy
you a plane ticket
anywhere and I like I always just like
well I don't think it really well um and
I don't know if it works with my
students either but I have I think
impressed upon some in some of my
communication some of my students in my
some of my children that taking less and
taking it later during this adolescent
period might enable you to enjoy it more
and more casually as an adult Oh
interesting so you're not encouraging
you know like total abstinence it's kind
of a more realistic maybe approach -
yeah I'm not against drug use at all I I
think I've used up my opportunity for it
but I do think that addiction is really
devastating to people and their families
and their communities so I think if we
can avoid the compensatory processes and
you can do that especially by not taking
a lot and not taking it while you're
young you know I think it's natural to
want to experiment and I think it's
interesting so based on your research
and what we know about how the brain
processes addiction is there an ideal
way to treat addiction is there
something that we do now that's closest
to working or maybe something that we're
thinking about doing yeah this is an
excellent question and of course it's
something that many of us care a lot
about there's certainly been a long
history of failed strategies we can see
that in our immediate history but also
doctors who've treated alcoholism with
heroin Freud in fact recommended cocaine
to his friend who was addicted to
morphine substitution is probably not
the best strategy in many cases but I
think it's also important to ask ideal
from whose perspective so methadone is
really cheap and fairly effective which
helps addicts not be so likely to commit
crimes for instance and/or overdose but
it's also a real ball and chain for an
addict so it doesn't increase their
freedom from drugs for instance antabuse
was used for alcohol addiction and it's
also not very effective so I think
one message at least from my perspective
is that we need to focus maybe more on
the demand rather than on the supply and
that education might have a big role to
play in that I really am
especially hopeful that what we learn
about how the brain adapts to chronic
drug exposure can be something that kind
of trickles down to general knowledge
kind of like when I was a kid we didn't
even wear seatbelts and now everybody
wears the seatbelt you know we didn't
use sunscreen and now that's just part
of being out on the in the Sun so I
think if we appreciated how great the
brain is at adapting and learned ways to
mitigate that prevent intense adaptation
by taking less especially or maybe not
getting so into it as a adolescent then
we might at least have fewer people to
treat Judy thank you so much
you're very welcome thank you that was
books editor Valerie Thompson speaking
with Judy grisel author of never enough
the neuroscience and experience of
addiction and that concludes this
edition of the science podcast if you
have any comments or suggestions for the
show write to us at science podcast at
AAAS 0rg I really appreciate all the
people who wrote in saying they would be
interested in the book reviewer position
we have found someone so thank you all
again for writing us and it was really
heartening to hear how many people
listened this far into the show so
amazing thank you guys you can subscribe
to the show anywhere you get your
podcasts or you can listen on the
science website that's science magnet or
podcast to place an ad on the show
contact mid-roll comm the show was
produced by Sarah crispy and Megan
Cantwell and edited by Paula G Jeffery
cook composed the music on behalf of
science magazine and its publisher
triple-a s thanks for joining us